[Music]
you're going to tell us everything you
know
i'm not telling you a mother
you can electrocute him all day it'll
only make him angrier i
on the other hand will tell you
everything really
michael bryce was trying to put his past
behind him you need to forget
bodyguarding repeat after me
no bodyguarding no
to protect this homicidal nut bags wife
what is he doing here
i said get anyone but michael rice
i believe it's pronounced thank you
in four days all of you love was burned
they're planning a full-scale cyber
attack do not scoop this up
but we are definitely going to screw
this up
i promised my therapist no body guarding
let's not do that guys let's just focus
i got it no it's fine you guys just you
guys have had him
maybe feather the break a bit i need you
to protect us
good time to have a baby
we gotta have mercy on ourselves now
repeat after me
i'm unlicensed i'm unlicensed that's
terrible
louder i'm unlicensed and i don't give
up
we need guns we need boats
we need them are you ready to get your
free con
what that came out wrong not together
with us that also came out wrong now
let's go do what we do
and blow some things up
i would make a great mother don't you
think i think your glasses thank you
it must be your powerful asexuality that
makes you such a good listener
we just acknowledge that not only are we
safe this really feels like a newbie
[Music]
you